houston son univers impitoyable houston
texas ville natale des zz top et
champion du monde du bouki juteux qui
fait des tâches le texas fête cette
année son 150e anniversaire et zz top se
devait de terminer à houston sa tournée
américaine
billy bones de dit pourquoi
[Musique]
pour trois nuits consécutives visiteurs
par an pile et 20000 places du summit
fille au teint ce qui est la moindre des
choses pour ces ambassadeurs du rock
texan qui ont réussi à plaire un très
large public
nous avons demandé aux fans de zz top ce
qu'il représente pour eux
[Musique]
je faisais
tu es un mot fond
je venais
les bleus restent aux mains
est
ça c'est la déléguée bonne soupe
basilic
[Musique]
à leur façon les trois lascars de zz top
sont des cow boys du xxème siècle raison
pour laquelle ils ont reçu le titre très
prisé est très rare de héros texan
officiel une récompense qu'il partage
avec des personnages historiques comme
davy crockett le débit croquettes et sam
houston le vainqueur de la bataille de
saint justin tôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut des heures de l'épreuve louvre
personal sont donc devenus des réfugiés
les diplômés je vous laisse le soin de
décortiquer l'ironie de la chose mais is
it up a maintenant quitté son texas
natal pour une tournée européenne qui
les mènera cette semaine en france bien
sûr billy bones voyage avec la célèbre
guitare chiquita dessiné par ses soins
il vous vante l'article 8 9
au centre
chacun
[Musique]